Our next case continues.
Our discussion of unconscionability.
Looking closely at one common type of contractor will provision arbitration
clauses.
The facts of this case are relatively straight forward.
Misty Ferguson was an employee of countrywide when she began working there.
She signed a contract which included a provision mandating that certain types of
disputes between her and countrywide would be arbitrated rather than going to
court.
She later filed a lawsuit in court for sexual harassment against countrywide and
her manager Leo Dileo when countrywide tried to force Ferguson to go to
arbitration,
the court refused to enforce the arbitration clause finding it to be
unconscionable
in the opinion you have read.
Judge Pregerson is reviewing that decision to see whether the arbitration clause
and Ferguson's employment contract was in fact unconscionable and therefore
unenforceable under California law.
Arbitration has come up a couple of times during this course but this case
delves into the arbitration process in more detail so it's worth saying a little
bit more about it.
Arbitration is an alternative to a a lawsuit in an ordinary court,
a neutral third party called the arbitrator gets still look at evidence here,
the parties arguments and decide the case.
The arbitrators decision is binding on the parties and it generally cannot be
appealed to a court.
The details of how an arbitration works.
For example,
how the arbitrator is selected,
what evidence can be presented,
etc. Are All determined by the contract in which the parties agreed to
arbitrate.
Some state courts have been skeptical about the impartiality of arbitrators and
the fairness of the arbitration process,
but Congress in 19 Tony five passed the Federal Arbitration Act or FAA to ensure
that courts would enforce arbitration agreements and less.
Those agreements were unenforceable because of some generally applicable state
contract law doctrine under the FAA estate cannot carve out special rules
limiting enforcement of arbitration agreements.
Those agreements can only be set aside for reasons that might also render other
types of agreements on enforceable.
Not Withstanding the FAA,
some state courts have remained hostile to the enforcement of arbitration
clause,
so much so that states like California have been willing to distort their
generally applicable law in order to reduce of arbitration agreements.
Judge Pregerson applies California law to determine whether the arbitration
clause in Ferguson this employment contract with contra countrywide is a valid
contract provision under California state law under California law to find an
arbitration clause unconscionable,
the judge must find both procedural unconscionability and substantive
unconscionability,
but the precise mix of these two elements can vary.
Quote,
the more substantively oppressive the contract term,
the less evidence of procedural unconscionability is required to come to the
conclusion that the term is unenforceable unquote.
Here the court finds both procedural and substantive unconscionability and so
the arbitration clause is unenforceable.
The court looks at two factors to determine procedural unconscionability,
which is about the fairness of the process by which the parties arrived at the
contract.
The first is oppression.
Did the parties have unequal bargaining power?
Was there actual meaningful negotiation between the parties and did both parties
have a choice here?
Ferguson had no ability to bargain to vary the terms of the agreement.
The contract was offered on a take it or leave it basis.
The second factor for procedural unconscionability is surprise.
Was the arbitration clause hidden.
The court didn't discuss the surprise question in detail,
but it seems to reject the Countrywide's claim.
That quote,
the contract was written in plain language.
One way that California hostility to arbitration clauses has distorted
unconscionability doctrine is by changing what constitutes procedural
unconscionability today in California,
any form contract that is offered on a take it or leave it basis is going to be
treated as having at least some degree of procedural unconscionability.
This means that the vast majority of consumer and employment contracts have are
going to be um,
procedurally unconscionable so that the question of unconscionability and
setting aside the term will turn solely on whether the contract is sufficiently
unconscionable in a substantive sense.
In discussing substantive unconscionability,
judge Pregerson focuses on the question of whether the terms of the agreement
quote are so one sided as to shock the conscience unquote.
He finds three ways in which they are substantively unconscionable.
First,
the arbitration clause only applies to the sorts of claims and employee like
Ferguson might bring against countrywide discrimination or harassment tort
claims,
but the clause leaves countrywide free to go to court for the sorts of claims
that it might bring against Ferguson violations of intellectual property or
unauthorized disclosure of trade secrets.
Second,
the contract forces Ferguson to bear a significant portion of the cost of
arbitration.
An earlier California Supreme Court decision had held that mandatory arbitration
clauses in employment contracts could only be enforceable if the cost to the
employee for arbitration was no more than the cost of going to court.
Splitting the arbitration fees with the employee by itself can be substantively
unconscionable.
The court found that countrywise fees to be substantially unconscionable because
they might be higher than an employee would pay in going to court.
Third,
the provisions of the contract that limit discovery in a way that
disproportionally d disadvantages.
Ferguson was found to be substantively unconscionable countrywide as the
employer likely has access to all sorts of information about what happened
without needing discovery.
While Ferguson needs discovery to have any information at all.
These three one sided aspects of the arbitration provision seem to judge
progress in like an intentional attempt by countrywide to bias the arbitration
process in its own favor.
And so he ruled that the whole arbitration clause was unconscionable and
therefore unenforceable.
But frankly,
the court's analysis of substantive unconscionability is hard to understand
except as an expression of judicial hostility toward enforcement of arbitration
agreements possibly,
especially when they,
uh,
are being used to deny an employee from having her day in court concerning the
civil rights claim.
Many individual provisions of a contract or by themselves one sided,
one provision might for example,
mandate that an employee worked 40 hours per week and not require anything of an
employer.
But of course,
another provision of that contract might one sidedly provide that the employer
must pay the employee.
Uh,
and here is it really one sided for the employer and employee to split the
arbitration fees.
Splitting seems the
opposite of one side.
This and employment provision that said employees had to send their kids to an
employer and employers private kindergarten is likely to be enforced even if the
fees were greater than what the employee would have to pay for public school.
The provision covering the kinds of actions that can be brought is one sided,
but the one sidedness might be reasonable.
Employers might be more subject to reputational discipline than employees,
especially today with social media that might justify asymmetric access to
courts.
In two recent cases,
the United States Supreme Court has overturned California law about the Ar
unconscionability of arbitration clauses at and t mobility versus Concepcion in
2011 and American Express versus Italian colors and 2013 both of these cases
dealt with provisions preventing class arbitration,
the arbitration equivalent of class action lawsuits,
and in both cases,
the u s supreme court overturned California decisions to say that arbitration
clauses were valid and enforceable.
The U s supreme court in a sense,
understands that states like California are manipulating unconscionability law
to end run the FAA,
and these two sovereigns can be seen as in a struggle over arbitration
enforceability.
So let's take a quiz.
Two companies negotiate a contract that includes an arbitration clause.
The arbitration clause says that one of the companies will have much more
extensive discovery powers in arbitration.
Then the other is the arbitration clause.
Unconscionable,
uh,
court probably wouldn't find this arbitration clause unconscionable.
Recall that unconscionability requires both procedural and substantive
unconscionability.
While this agreement might be lopsided enough to be substantively
unconscionable,
it seems like the two companies had a real opportunity to negotiate the terms of
the contract until the contract is not procedurally unconscionable.
Whichever company gave up its discovery powers probably got something else in
exchange.
Okay.
Under California law,
arbitration clauses are invalid.
If there are no opportunity to negotiate,
that would be procedural unconscionability.
And the arbitration process is stacked against the weaker party.
That would be substantive unconscionability.
But the state's application of these rules are in flux because of the federal
state tensions regarding arbitration enforcement.